هل يمكن فعل أي شيء لمنع
انتشار المواد الإباحية المزيفة مثل
الصور المزيفة التي تم إنشاؤها بواسطة الذكاء الاصطناعي لتايلور سويفت
والتي انتشرت على نطاق واسع على X؟ حسنًا، ربما
يمكن العثور على الإجابة في البريد الإلكتروني العشوائي،
ولهذا السبب يتسابق المشرعون الآن لمحاولة
إيقاف هذا الانفجار وغيره  -التفكير التوافقي في
الذكاء الاصطناعي ولكن هناك حقيقة صعبة حول هذا الأمر
وهي أنه من
الصعب للغاية إيقاف هذه الأشياء من الناحية التكنولوجية، وهناك مشكلتان مؤثرتان
تجعلان مكافحتها تحديًا،
الأولى هي كيفية إنشاء الذكاء الاصطناعي للصور، والأخرى
هي كيفية انتشار تلك الصور،
فلنتحدث عن  أولًا، هذا الانفجار في
توليد صور الذكاء الاصطناعي الذي رأيناه،
ردًا على شركات التكنولوجيا التي تصنع
منتجات الذكاء الاصطناعي مثل الانتشار الأساسي، فقد
فعلت أشياء مثل إزالة صور البالغين
من مجموعات التدريب الخاصة بها لتجعل من الصعب
إخراج صور البالغين ولكن المشكلة
هي  أنك في الوقت الحالي لا تحتاج إلى بعض
مزرعة الخوادم الفاخرة
والتكنولوجيا المتطورة لجعل
مولدات الصور مفتوحة المصدر التي تعمل على حل الذكاء الاصطناعي موجودة على
أجهزة الكمبيوتر الخاصة بالأشخاص، ومعجون الأسنان هنا خارج
الأنبوب، لذا هناك سؤال
حول كيفية انتشار تلك الصور و
صور تايلور سويفت المزيفة التي انتشرت
بسرعة على X، تمت مشاهدتها عشرات
الملايين من المرات، تلك الصور إلى جانب
الصور الإباحية المزيفة العميقة الأخرى
محظورة بالفعل من قبل الموقع، ومع ذلك
فهي لا تزال تنتشر بشكل مثالي لدرجة أنك ترغب في
إنشاء شيء يمكنه
اكتشافها تلقائيًا و  ثم قم بحظر أي صور
قد تتمكن من اختراق الشقوق.
لكن المشكلة تكمن في أن
اكتشاف ما هو صورة ذكاء اصطناعي وما هو ليس صورة ذكاء اصطناعي بشكل موثوق هو أمر صعب للغاية
وأصعب بكثير
من مجرد إنشاء صور ذكاء اصطناعي
نفسها والعديد من الشركات في الوقت
الحالي  نعمل على إنشاء
تقنية للكشف عن التزييف العميق، ولكن مع
تحسن هذه التكنولوجيا، تتحسن صور الذكاء الاصطناعي
نفسها، لذلك بدون أي
كشف تلقائي موثوق يعمل
على نطاق واسع، فإن أفضل أمل الآن هو
منع انتشار تلك الصور ولكن الذكاء الاصطناعي
رخيص جدًا وسهل الاستخدام.  استخدم أنه حتى لو تم
تحديد صورة واحدة على أنها سيئة مثل
صور تايلور سويفت، فيمكن لشخص ما التقاطها
ثم ضخ مليون
شكل مختلف قليلاً، فهناك
طرق أخرى مع تايلور سويفت X لديها
الآن عمليات بحث محدودة لجعل
العثور عليها أكثر صعوبة ولكن تلك  هذا النوع من
القيود الصارمة لا يمكن أن يصل إلى
أبعد من ذلك، فهل هناك أي شيء يمكننا
القيام به بشكل جيد في الماضي، هناك
في الواقع مثال واحد يعطي
الأمل، قال الخبراء الذين تحدثت إليهم إن أفضل
سيناريو في مكافحة
المواد الإباحية غير التوافقية التي تعتمد على الذكاء الاصطناعي يمكن أن  ما
حدث للبريد الإلكتروني العشوائي، لذلك في التسعينيات، أدى
البريد الإلكتروني العشوائي إلى ازدحام
صناديق بريد الجميع، وبدا أن هذه
المشكلة المستعصية التي كان من المستحيل
إصلاح مقدار الأميال التي يتم
إنشاؤها ستؤدي إلى انهيار النظام،
ثم تغيرت الأمور من الناحية التكنولوجية، حيث
طورت شركات مثل Google
مرشحات متقدمة لـ  تم تغيير القوانين للتخلص منها
وأصبحت الشركات التي تقف وراء
رسائل البريد الإلكتروني العشوائي مسؤولة عن غرامات كبيرة
وعقوبات جنائية، لذلك تتسابق الكثير من الشركات
لحل مشكلة القط والفأر
التكنولوجية، فهل يمكن لجهودهم
جنبًا إلى جنب مع الإجراءات القانونية تكرار
نجاح مرشحات البريد الإلكتروني العشوائي بشكل جيد  بالنسبة
لأهداف صور الذكاء الاصطناعي غير التوافقية
مثل تايلور سويفت،
يمكن القول إن الحاجة إلى العمل أكثر إلحاحًا بكثير